[Music]
i call it a sport because it's
working your brain
i feel very passionate about it
[Music]
i think i'm good at it
chess is a fun game to play
i don't like it i love it
hey hey
we wanted to give kids an opportunity to
problem solve and to think outside of
the box
you don't see it chess is something that
can hopefully broaden those horizons for
them in the future
equal the playing field give them
conversation topics on job interviews
your turn my first piece
you have to be focused and not be
talking
because you never know if they take a
piece that you didn't want them to take
you focus hey i can take your push-up
you
focus on the game and you you can't let
stuff around you distract you
girls think it's mainly a boy's thing
that's why i was like hey i'm a girl i'm
not a boy
i can do whatever boys can do the game
of strategy and i have
lots of strategies well i like it
because
it's like life if you want to do
something with your life you can be a
king
or for girls you can be a queen but
i say i just don't want to be a pond
[Laughter]
everybody wants to be the king right
we are going to talk about starting out
the game doing some opening strategies
my personal we are working on curriculum
and
it's i do think it helps with critical
thinking skills because
with my experience in math you have to
think ahead you have to think you know
what am i trying to achieve here with
this mathematical problem
well yes it's the same thing i can tell
you that those cognitive skills are
really important that critical thinking
kind of
thinking about what mood to make next
and how to really anticipate one move
as opposed to another that same efficacy
transfers to the classroom as well i'm
thinking about
doing the sneak attack and at the
beginning of the game
oh as an educator it's phenomenal i hope
the strategic planning of chess
will cause them to just slow down in
life and think before
they speak think before they move
anticipate what's going to happen next
and choose the right path i think it
keeps my mind sharp because
if you plan three moves ahead you you
know what's coming next
you know where not to move to learn the
importance of
the choice you make today is going to
affect the choices you make later
here in this world it'll teach you out
and about
how to look around make sure you're safe
keep your head up
when we go to tournaments i play against
different people so i know i get better
when we started going to the tournaments
and they they were nervous
i was nervous we'd never done that
before so when they got there and they
won a game
i was excited for them to see see you're
good enough to play in the tournament
you're on check me dude it's like
it's very fun and even if i lose all i
gotta do is work on it
and i know how to lose i'm not a sore
loser if i lose i lose
i think it builds democracy students
become ambassadors
for the school district and for
themselves they see where they fit in
the grander scheme
and that's where i think they become
validated
that i am a part of this community i'm a
part of this world
and i gotta find my rightful place i
matter
you have to move out of check
okay being confident that
can make hard stuff easy
as a parent i want my son to be an
intelligent young man
i know that this helps him learning to
think learning to fight through your
emotions
learning to not overestimate or
underestimate your opponent
learning to you know all the strategies
that make you a good chess player are
going to help him
as he develops into a man thank you for
letting for letting me
know that i like chess and be more
confident in myself
thank you very much thank you for
donating
money to the chess program because i
really enjoy chess
[Music]
thank you it's your move now
you